[Música]
empezamos nuestro segmento especial
camino a la casa blanca a dos semanas
para las elecciones esto es lo que usted
necesita saber el presidente de donald
trump y el candidato demócrata joe biden
se enfocaron en florida esta semana un
estado clave que otorga a 29 delegados
al colegio electoral el organismo que
elige al presidente de eeuu y donde se
requieren 270 para ganar se trata de un
swing states es decir pendular o bisagra
que no tiene una tradición clara
demócrata o republicana los latinos allí
representan el 26 por ciento de la
población pero su voto no es homogéneo
si bien históricamente los hispanos se
han identificado con los demócratas
debido a su origen la diáspora cubana
venezolana y colombiana tiende a ser más
conservadora ya que en el caso de
venezuela y cuba vieron como los
gobiernos de izquierdas llevaron a sus
países a las crisis mientras que en
colombia se asocia con la extinta
guerrilla de las farc en un mitin en
sanford son pablo de los dos vecinos
suramericanos
crítico del acuerdo de paz del gobierno
de juan manuel santos con la ex
guerrilla de las farc y celebro la
puesta en libertad del ex presidente
colombiano álvaro uribe vélez además
vinculó a job airén con el llamado
castrochavismo el neologismo para
referirse a las políticas de los
fallecidos fidel castro y hugo chávez
por su parte bardem intentó alejarse de
los señalamientos diciendo que
precisamente le ganó al representante
del ala más izquierdista de su partido
bernie sanders
vamos a miami para hablar con nuestro
corresponsal anthony welsch anthony te
pregunto en cifras qué porcentaje de
votos representan los venezolanos y los
colombianos en miami
pues si natalia primero todo para
entender cómo se distribuye ese mapa
electoral aquí en florida hay que
entender que es 26 4% de los hispanos
que van a votar porque que son elegibles
para votar representan el 1 millón poco
más de un millón y medio de personas en
este estado la mayor parte del pastel se
la llevan los cubanos con unos 650 mil
personas y luego estarían los
colombianos unas 190.000 y ya por último
los la nueva tanda del exilio venezolano
que ha llegado a florida completamente
al sur que representarían unos 50 mil
por eso la campaña de joe biden y
también la detona al tram especialmente
se está fijando en esos votos porque
básicamente porque así nos remontamos
hace cuatro años
hillary clinton perdió en este estado
por tan sólo 130 mil votos
y por qué no hacen mella entre los
hispanos en florida de las palabras de
trump contra los migrantes especialmente
los mexicanos y los centroamericanos
y principalmente porque los cubanos los
cubanoamericanos nunca han tenido
problemas migratorios de hecho se han
beneficiado de las políticas
estadounidenses cualquiera que llegaba
hasta este país pues en un año podía
legalizar sus papeles lo mismo pasa
también con los colombianos o los
venezolanos que pueden acogerse a
algunos beneficios e inmigratorios como
el asilo por eso el tema migratorio aquí
en florida no es un tema tan importante
tan destacable como podrían ser en otras
zonas de estados unidos como méxico o
incluso tejas donde la población
mexicana y centroamericana también es
muy abundante y realmente baida en
representar el castrochavismo o se está
traduciendo la polarización que ya
existen en sus países en la contienda de
eeuu
y cualquiera que sepa o entienda un poco
de política de estadounidenses sabe que
este país eeuu no se puede convertir en
un país comunista de un día para otro es
un mensaje que el presidente tram está
repitiendo una y otra vez pero detrás de
este mensaje está la posibilidad la
intención de poder captar esos votos de
la comunidad venezolana especialmente
porque si realmente se confirma que el
98 por ciento de los elegibles a votar
van a ir a las urnas pues podrían marcar
la diferencia en este estado y
recordemos que es quien gana florida
gana las elecciones presidenciales ha
sido así desde el año 1996 y sólo en dos
ocasiones desde 1924 no había pasado
algo así gracias antonio antón nivel si
es nuestro corresponsal en miami por
participar en este segmento especial de
aquí a américa camino a la causa
y a ustedes gracias por acompañarme en
esta emisión recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho del coronavirus y sigan
viendo para nos 24
[Música]